I wonder what we're gonna see in this
hitman 2 demo today I'm just so excited
to see hitman two I'm gonna kill so many
people so so I told them pub G on
console I'd rather play on my phone hi
Jen what are you guys doing here oh well
well it isn't GameSpot IGN fancy seeing
you here
did you guys figure out what your name
stands for yet huh at least we don't get
confused it's game stuff you guys are
like the blue shell of pizzas already
enough the gaming pun so I'll cut
straight to the point you're
overstepping to our territory what are
you even doing here there's supposed to
be our exclusive demo got this
mysterious invitation in the mail
I think we're here to play some hitman
two ladies and gentlemen of GameSpot and
IGN
you're both formidable teams but which
of you are worthy of the title the
ultimate hitman in Colombia there are
three targets and it's your team's job
to pull off the perfect hit however if
you wanted to do this the old-fashioned
way we would have just hired agent 47
instead you're going to assassinate them
to the most unique way you can your team
must grab the plan to deal with each
target the more creative the kill the
better then you will compete live
against one another on launch day to see
who can execute the plan the most
efficiently your panic rooms await
beyond these doors who would be the
ultimate hitman of gaming will soon find
out now go our initial first note we're
gonna go in this cave a system that's
gonna be a really good way to get to the
target okay idea okay so the targets are
in a mansion a village and a field
laboratory wait so they get guns and we
get rubber ducks
we should kill that shaman take his
costume and then not even use it so
proud of you man
something makes a concrete way to get a
ton of points this is great if we're
just bush boys all the time they'll
never find us
maybe instead of murdering war hey we
should probably try to find him a
chiropractor I guess that also works man
talk about a nice situation
[Music]
that's coffee yeah good
good talk ya see out there all right
guys I feel really good about our plan
we did it it's perfect
watch GameSpot the place to be feel a
good man what we would say talk
[Music]
[Music]
I can't wait to bring you all down with
the whole world watch please be me you
guys will be easier than getting a
platinum trophy in spider-man are you
guys kidding me beating you guys is
gonna be easier than getting a chicken
dinner
hey I love you guys in Kingdom Hearts 2
who did you play again the nobodies the
only party you guys were invited to this
year was Mario's Oh somebody called
Delilah from Firewatch because that was
a bird guys wait
and settle this on launch day forgot who
the real hit men are fine launch day it
is see that be sure to tune in on
November 13th to see what happens next
Greg Miller will host our showdown live
as we pull off our plans as well as
compete in the all-new ghost mode
IGN vs. GameSpot it's on